[Music]
billions of years ago on the young
planet earth simple organic compounds
assembled into more complex coalition's
that could grow and reproduce they were
the very first life on Earth and they
gave rise to every one of the billions
of species that have inhabited our
planet since at the time earth was
almost completely devoid of what we'd
recognize as a suitable environment for
living things the young planet had
widespread volcanic activity and an
atmosphere that created hostile
conditions so where on earth could life
begin to begin the search for the cradle
of life it's important to first
understand the basic necessities for any
life form elements and compounds
essential to life include hydrogen
methane nitrogen carbon dioxide
phosphates and ammonia in order for
these ingredients to co-mingle and react
with each other they need a liquid
solvent water and in order to grow and
reproduce all life needs a source of
energy life-forms are divided into two
camps
autotrophs like plants that generate
their own energy and heterotrophs like
animals that consume other organisms for
energy
the first life-form wouldn't have had
other organisms to consume of course so
it must have been an autotroph
generating energy either from the Sun or
from chemical gradients so what
locations meet these criteria places on
land or close to the surface of the
ocean have the advantage of access to
sunlight but at the time when life began
the UV radiation on Earth's surface was
likely too harsh for life to survive
there one setting offers protection from
this radiation and an alternative
energy source the hydrothermal vents
that lined across the ocean floor
covered by kilometers of sea water and
bathed in complete darkness a
hydrothermal vent is a fissure in the
Earth's crust where sea water seeps into
magma chambers and is ejected back out
at high temperatures along with a rich
slurry of minerals and simple chemical
compounds energy is particularly
concentrated at the steep chemical
gradients of hydrothermal vents there's
another line of evidence that points to
hydrothermal vents the last Universal
common ancestor of life for Luca for
short Luca wasn't the first life-form
but it's as far back as we can trace
even so we don't actually know what Luca
looks like there's no Luca fossil no
modern-day Luca still around instead
scientists identified genes that are
commonly found in species across all
three domains of life that exists today
since these genes are shared across
species and domains they must have been
inherited from a common ancestor these
shared genes tell us that Luca lived in
a hot oxygen-free place and harvested
energy from a chemical gradient like the
ones at hydrothermal vents there are two
kinds of hydrothermal vent black smokers
and white smokers black smokers release
acidic carbon dioxide rich water heated
to hundreds of degrees Celsius and
packed with sulfur iron copper and other
metals essential to life but scientists
now believe that black smokers were too
hot for Luca so now the top candidates
for the Cradle of Life are white smokers
among the white smokers a field of
hydrothermal vents on the mid-atlantic
ridge called lost city has become the
most favored candidate for the Cradle of
Life the seawater expelled here is in
highly alkaline and lacks carbon dioxide
but is rich in methane and offers more
hospitable temperatures adjacent black
smokers may have contributed the carbon
dioxide necessary for life to evolve at
lost city giving it all the components
to support the first organisms that
radiated into the incredible diversity
of life on Earth today did you know that
a single-celled organism caused the
first mass extinction
check out this animation about how it
almost wiped out life on Earth and paved
the way for complex life
[Music]